let me ask about this entity that you
call sarah
yes i talk to myself i put myself in
third person sometimes
i don't know why uh so
maybe this is a good time to bring up
consciousness sure
it's been here all along well has it so
what i mean at least in this
conversation i think i've been conscious
most of it but maybe i haven't
well yeah speak so speak for yourself
you're you're
you're projecting your consciousness
onto me you don't know if i'm conscious
or not
is it um you're right is that uh
he talked about the physics of existence
he talked about the emergence
of um of causality uh sorry
you talked about causality and time
being fundamental to the universe
where does consciousness fit into all of
this like uh
do you do you draw any kind of
inspiration or value
with the idea of pan psychism that maybe
one of the things that we ought to
understand is the physics of
consciousness
like one of the missing pieces
in the physics view of the world is
understanding the physics of
consciousness
or like that word has so many concepts
underneath it but let's put it let's put
consciousness as a label on a black box
of mystery that we don't understand
do you think that black box holds the
key
to uh finally answering the question of
the physics of life
the problems are absolutely related i
think most and i'm interested in both
because i'm just interested in what we
are
and to me the most interesting feature
of what we are is our minds and the way
they interact with other minds
like minds are the most beautiful thing
that exists in the universe so how do
they come to be
sorry to interrupt so when you say we
you mean humans
i mean humans right now but i but that's
because i'm a human or at least i think
i am
you think there's something special to
this particular no no no
um no um i don't
i'm not a human-centric thinker but are
you one entity you said
a bunch of stuff came together to make a
sarah like gg
as one entity are you just a bunch of
different components like is there any
value to understand
the physics of sarah like or are you
just a bunch of different things that
are like a nice little temporary side
effect
yeah you you could think of me as a
bundle of information that just
became temporarily aggregated or
individual yeah that's fine
i agree with that view um
okay that is a compliment actually but
you you've
but nevertheless that bundle of
information has become conscious
or at least keeps calling her
self-conscious
yeah i think i'm conscious right now but
i might not be but that's okay
um or you wouldn't know um so yeah so
this is the problem so
yeah usually people when they're talking
about consciousness are worried about
the subjective experience and so i think
that's why you're saying
i don't know if you're conscious because
i don't know if you're experiencing this
conversation right now
um and nor do you know if i'm
experienced in the conversation right
now
um and so this is why this is called the
hard problem of consciousness because it
seems impenetrable from the outside to
know if something's having
a conscious experience um and i really
like um
uh the idea of also like the hard
problem of matter which is
related to the hard problem of
consciousness which is you don't know
the intrinsic properties of an electron
not interacting say for example with
anything else in the universe all the
properties of
anything that exists in the universe are
divine by its interaction because you
have to interact with it in order to be
able to observe it so we can only
actually
know the things that are observable from
the outside and so this is one of the
reasons that consciousness is hard for
science because you're asking questions
about something that's subjective and
supposed to be intrinsic to what that
thing is
as it exists and how it feels about
existing um
and so i have thought a lot about this
problem and its relationship
to the problem of life and the only
thing i can come up with to try to make
that problem scientifically tractable
and also related to how i think about
the physics
of life is to ask the question
are there things that can only happen in
the universe
because there are physical systems that
have subjective experience
so does subjective experience have
different causes
that things that it can cause to occur
um
that would happen in the absence of that
i don't know the answer to that question
but i think that's a meaningful ask way
of asking the question of consciousness
i can't ask
if you're having experience right now
but i can ask if you have having
experience
right now changes something about you
and the way you interact with the world
so does stuff happen it's just
it's a good question it has to stuff
happen if consciousness is
then it's a real physical thing right it
has physical consequences i'm a
physicist i'm biased so i don't
you know i can't get rid of that bias
it's really deeply ingrained
um i've tried but i mean you're
saying information is physical too so
like virtual reality simulation all that
program is physical too
yes everything's physical it's just not
physical the way it's represented in our
minds
right so you i love your twitter so you
tweet these like deep
thoughts and deep dust that's what a
theorist does when she's trying to
experiment
his tweet it's just like sitting there
i mean i can just imagine you sitting
there for like hours and all of a sudden
just like
this thought comes out and it would get
a little um
like inkling into the thought process
yeah usually it's like when i'm running
between things
yeah so you thoughts are hard to
articulate one of the things you tweeted
is
ideologically there are many parallels
between the search
for neural correlates of consciousness
and for chemical correlates of life
how the neuroscience and astrobiology
communities
treat those correlates is entirely
different can you
elaborate against this kind of yeah the
parallels
it has to do a little bit with the
consciousness and the and the
and the matter thing you're talking
about yeah it does and i i can't
remember what state of mind i was when i
was actually thinking about that but um
but i think part of it is but you never
thought you're gonna have to analyze
your own twist
no i didn't it's an interesting uh
historical juxtaposition of
thinking so the tweet is a historical uh
you're doing an assembly experiment
right now because you're bringing a
thought from the past into the present
and trying to actually
in the lab yeah yeah yeah this is this
is experimental science right here okay
on the podcast live um
so so go let's see how the consciousness
evolves on this one
yeah so um in neuroscience it's kind of
accepted that we can't get it the
subjective
aspect of consciousness so people are
very interested
in what would be a correlate of
consciousness so
um so that's a correlation a correlate
is
a feature that relates to conscious
activity so for example
um you know a verbal report is a
correlate of consciousness because
um you know i can tell you when i'm
conscious and then
when i'm sleeping for example i can't
tell you i'm conscious so we have this
assumption that you're
not conscious when you're sleeping and
you're conscious when you're awake yeah
um and so so that's sort of like a very
obvious example but neuroscientists
which you know i'm no neuroscientist and
i'm not an expert in this field so
um but you know they have very
sophisticated ways of measuring you know
activity in our brain and trying to
relate that to
verbal report and other proxies for
whether someone is experiencing
something
and that's what is meant by neural
correlates
and then so when people are trying to
think about
studying consciousness or developing
theories for consciousness
they often are trying to build an
experimental bridge
to these neural correlates recognizing
the fact that a neural correlate
may or may not correspond to
consciousness because
that problem's hard and there's all
these associated issues to it
so that that's from a neuroscience
perspective it's like fake it till you
make it so you pretty much yeah
you fake whatever the correlates are and
hopefully that
the uh that's going to uh summon the
thing that is consciousness or something
like that and so the same thing
on the chemical correlates of life is
that sounds like that's an awesome
concept is that something that people
no i just made that up okay that was an
original to that tweet you can cite the
tweet
maybe i'll write it in a paper someday
uh chemical correlates of life that's a
good title
i mean first of all your your papers too
that people should check out have great
titles
or paper papers you're involved with so
your tweets and titles
are are stellar and also your ideas but
the tweets and titles are much more
important
of course so these will live longer
yeah they're much more diffused though
um
well it's yeah it's the george tweet is
the trojan horse the idea that
that sticks on for a long time okay so
is there anything to say about the
chemical coils a lot you're saying
there are similar kind of ways of
thinking about it
but uh you mentioned
about the communities yeah so i think in
astrobiology it's not
um there's no concept of chemical
correlates of life we don't think about
it that way we think
if we find molecules that are involved
in biology we
found life so i think i i
i think one of my motivations there was
just to separate the fact that
life has abstract properties associated
to it they become imprinted in
material substrates um and those
substrates are correlates for that thing
but they are not necessarily the thing
we're actually looking for the thing
that we're looking for
is the physics that's organizing that
system to begin with not the particular
molecules
um in the same sense that that you know
your consciousness is
is not your brain it's it's it's it
it's instantiated in your brain that you
know it has to have a physical
substrate but it's not the the matter is
not the thing that you're looking at
it's some other
at least not in the way that we have
come to look at matter
you know with traditional physics and
things there's there's something else
there and
it might be this feature of history i
was talking about our time being
actually you know physically represented
there do you think
consciousness can be engineered yes
in the same way that life can be well
that was a fast answer i didn't even
think about that that's interesting
you don't have a free will that was no i
do have free will but it's interesting
because some i mean
i you know you know you're backtracking
no no and that was predestined
yeah no no um no i do believe in free
will but i also
think that they're saying it kind of an
interesting um you know like what you're
you speaking about consciousness what
are you consciously aware of versus like
what is your subconscious brain actually
processing and doing and
and sometimes there's conflict between
your consciousness and your
subconsciousness or
your consciousness a little slower than
your subconscious and intuition
is a really important feature of that
and so a lot of the ways i do my science
is guided by intuition
so when i give fast answers like that i
think it's usually because i haven't
really thought about them and therefore
that's probably
telling me something
you